لا أعرف ما الذي فعلوه وقد فعله وهو
في حالة سبات ولكن هنا نعتني به على مدار
24 ساعة
لدينا ميزات رائعة وأطباء حريصون
وراءه كل التفاصيل ،
لذا فهو
دائمًا في الأندية التي تحدثنا عنها.  من
الصعب بالنسبة لي أن
أفهم متى تنفق الكثير من المال
مع اللاعبين وكيف عشت فيهم ،
لا أعرف ما هي الأندية الأخرى ، فأنا أؤدي
تجربتي في الماضي ،
لذا اليوم المنظمة مع هذا
الجدول الزمني الصعب  كل ثلاثة أربعة أيام
خلف اللاعبين ، يجب أن تكون
حاشية رائعة لتعتني
بهم ، إنه أمر شديد الصعوبة اليوم
وللتغذية والباقي والنوم
والطعام والتدريب كم عدد
الدقائق التي تعرف أن
هناك أيامًا لا يستطيعون القيام بها  تدرب
أكثر من 10 15 دقيقة وإلا
ستكون مخاطرة كما تعلم والناس يقولون
لماذا نستبدل
ضد أه أحمر الشفاه عند تسجيل
الأهداف أو كيف البديل ضد
الفريق اللاتيني بعد يوم واحد بعد
إصابته بعد مباراة بيرلي كان 10  أيام 15
يومًا من اللعب مع النرويج
لا يمكن أن يلعب معنا ضد ليفربول
لأننا نعلم أنه يجب أن يكون ذلك مثل
الساعة التي تعرفها لأنها كبيرة جدًا
يجب أن تكون
تدليكًا شريرًا وظهرًا وكتفيًا
ومشكلته في أوتار و
كل شيء ، لذا عليك أن تكون كما لو كان
يعمل كثيرًا كثيرًا من الوقت ولكن
الكثير من الوقت
داخل القطار الذي وضعه على الشاطئ